you
goddamn $120 [ __ ] yeah I paid for the
crab Thank You L ass experts I gotta go
to Vegas with him I got somebody telling
me to fix this [ __ ] drop thing back
here he is it's two seconds of that
effort but we actually have something
being built we have a special backdrop
being built being commissioned right now
for that so is it gonna be a wall that's
like here no it's gonna be back to where
that on the same place you want to see
the door no I don't really care about
the door but if I do it where the door
comes like in front of the door there's
nothing a little walk around the hallway
no that sucks
yeah that's but then there's like I'm
missing what you're going for here
that's all that's and that's my fault I
don't have your vision yeah and that's
my fault yeah well you're also 30 years
older than us so now you can't blame and
so you really don't have the 30 years 20
years old
do you way you just don't understand art
like we do I guess Fine Arts you know
we're like is the fine part about it my
degree doesn't they eat me warm and I
were start and Sam and Sam we're but
this is it's our yeah yeah this is art
Oh
somebody just gave you two dollars and
wants to know that's great how Matt how
did you use to clean money
clean money mm-hmm you didn't have to
clean money did you well no because it's
coming from Alone's
right exact straighted but as far as
like if I borrow if I think this is what
he's saying like if you borrow move it
around right if I borrow a bunch of
money in the name of Gary Sullivan how
do I get it into an account where the
government know there's somebody and
right at that time there was no Bitcoin
and there was no so and I didn't realize
I had I had that I went to prison I met
a bunch of people so you realize okay
you could have bought diamonds you could
have bought gold you could have there's
ways to launder it right well the only
thing I could think of at the time was
get it out in cash yeah I get out in
cash
we put it back into another bank account
or you could put it in there's ways to
get it you buy some real estate and just
say yeah I paying a rent is this much
and you go buy money orders you just
deposit the money and so you know this
you could buy a house for $40,000
there's a [ __ ] house it's gonna be
worth a hundred thousand once it's
renovated mm-hmm
but you got to put 40,000 renovations
well you can put the 40,000 renovations
and you just don't say you did anything
you say I bought it for 40 and I sold it
for a hundred well there's $60,000 worth
of money that you can now say look I
bought a house for 40 I sold it for 400
I made 60 grand well really only made 10
or 20 grand they don't know that so you
just made 40 grand cash earn or you just
laundered fortune ladies do it like that
but in my opinion it was like I was just
trying to get it out that's why I would
go in the bank and get out like ninth
hour I'd open up ten different bank
accounts and four different names and
I'd go get fifty five thousand today at
this account seven this one nine three
every couple of days and then I would
direct put direct deposit money into
each other's account so that they didn't
just drain they were the balances we're
doing this all the time and then one day
they just go it seems like a lot full
track of there's money you know you take
a cashier's check or you direct deposit
here you take out seven that you put in
thirty thousand you say oh by the way
can I get seven thousand in cash sure no
problem
that were the balances or and I would
get the money out and then now I've got
a [ __ ] duffel bag full of money you
just gotta put into another so I mean I
wasn't super sophisticated yeah because
there was no Bitcoin in 2006 well I
would bicker five different well because
then I could just buy bit corn and then
you put it into your electronic wallet
really that government you know because
it's because it's encrypted yeah they'd
and you they now don't know where the
money is all we know is he bought
Bitcoin if you then transfer that money
into another Bank count they don't
really know where it came from where it
came from
okay and where it disappeared to or you
could buy gold so they can't track that
right so you go buy gold you go buy
diamonds so I could you go buy a hundred
thousand dollars gold here and go across
the street to another gold dealer and
sell them the same money you lose
six percent but what does it matter
right now you deposited into your bank
account or or you get a check for it and
you go deposit into some corporation or
whatever
look as long as you're paying taxes on
it and you can if you're ever audited
they you can say this is where I got the
money and there's tons of ways to
launder money but look I wasn't that
sophisticated and one that big of a deal
at the time anyway yeah there wasn't
that much money and wasn't that
concerned shitty answer but that's fine
someone just dropped ten dollars for
your leg extension surgery nice what
anonymous American you are a true
American Hero
thank you for your service and we
appreciate you being there what hurt lay
that's just cruel it just means out of
nowhere people know we weren't even
talking about legs this mean
mean-spirited but thanks for the money
yeah that's for Danny Danny and Danny
didn't even hear the $10 so he's gonna
keep that ten oh damn he's keeping the
$10 Helen you fraud he's gone buddy hey
here's another one
I'll drop another hundred dollars if
Danny kills the bottle of Jack Daniels
in one drink and Matt squirts a bottle
of water in his face when he finishes
the bottle from this angle I thought
there was just a little that was too
much he's probably outside throwing up
right now from the people want to know
the biggest purchase he ever made the
biggest purchase I ever made mm-hmm
money-wise whatever those expensive car
car for one time for you to talk about
like a Rolex or something here's the
thing I mean here's the thing I buy
expensive I bought a tent
Rolex well that's difference that's just
you buy one not for ten grand I bought I
bought like an $8,000 one I've had a
couple of the little but what were the
in the the way I've never got like a
president like 20,000 our presidential
know what am I'm not a [ __ ] at night
it's just stupid like that look I had a
couple submariners you know they're
cheap they're like five six grand
yeah I mean that's not I'm not saying
that's cheap I'm saying it's not a
$20,000 $30,000 presidential it's not
crazy it's is I was about to say
reasonable you know when I see the other
day when I was talking I was broke I
only had 80 grand in cash I had no money
guys went nuts like that's not broke you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but I'm saying so what like a car like I
bought a car for like nineteen ninety
five thousand dollars it was in Audi but
it was finance or I bought houses I
bought a 200 ok the $250,000 house you
know I'm not sure those are it's a tough
question because yeah yeah but but it is
it a purchase when I got the bank to
lend me two hundred thousand of the two
I really put out 25 ran or 30 grand so
you know it's like is that everyone
thought like something with a big wad of
cash or nothing like I'm buying this
Mercedes in eighty thousand cash now
know why what I can finance it I
wouldn't go buy something for 50 or 60
grand cash but I know I you know I can
put down five grand and get it financed
know I can cause I can get it cars
houses anything like that anything
security which I'm getting by right
[ __ ] spinning 60 grand or 70 grand on
a car that I can get financed right it's
too easy to make some pay stubs and and
cover my employment and do a fake
identity what do you think about all
like the rappers that go on spend all
the money on their going broke trying to
prove how much money they they're going
broke trying to prove they're rich
that's just it's just complete stupidity
and anybody who's impressed by that kind
of stuff is just they just they're just
uncouth I'm
that's a word my mom uses not America
native people drop none 10 what were you
talking about somebody gave you $10 to
give me for my leg extension actually
gave 20 $20 consider doing that listen I
die Sears I told you Becky I know back
then but what you can start doing it now
now that you're past 50 years old would
you still do it I seem so silly and my
arms are so short I would do a mock-up
of what you would look like after your
legs yeah I just put my head on on a
t-rex we can make like a little
animation Thank You Kate make this up
that'll be one of your things it'll be
my head on a little t-rex of the arm
thank you thank you
oh my god there's so much Fine Arts
[ __ ] IQ in this room right now it's
mind-blowing somebody said they give
$100 yeah if you finished the rest of
the Jack Daniels and then Matt hit you
in the face with a bottle of water I'm
willing for $100 hell no yeah you what
would it take for him for me to chug the
rest of the Jack Daniels oh yeah $1,000
thousand bucks you heard it people right
you heard it right here 1001 big uns and
then I have to split it with Matt mm my
money he's got a dollars of my money
already
Yeah right now keep it on the board Sam
write it on the board yourself go back
in your ears that is gnarly
no no that is like a serious surgery do
that no he was thinking about it but the
girl at you away like do it he didn't
trust her
where how huh you have to leave the
country he'll do it here they basically
they convey they gave somebody a head
transplant swear it's real gonna have a
new body guarantee you in Mexico if we
get up to like two grain we can extend
all four oh my god Matt Cox is gonna
look like LeBron James afterward no it's
gonna be like 2k when you just max out
all this - money have you think you
think LeBron James is spent on his hair
have you seen you know and all that I
wonder how much leg arm extensions I
want the 50 that listen I need this
money coming in for me I'm not sure I'll
give it to you oh my god I'll give it to
you what's the tab at right now 110 you
can't add it up I don't think it's 60 20
and 50 there's a couple Hondo's in there
I'll give it all to you
well donated automatic talks I don't
want any of that donate donation all
demands but like the bronchi actually
they break your legs right and your what
your shins that bones they break your
[ __ ] to your femurs no no your femurs
why wait wait doesn't this thigh have to
be in proportion with the shin
no idea I like really long and then they
extend it slowly and the bone keeps
trying to grow together so it they'd
it'll grow together then they break it
again it keeps growing together they so
it takes six months to a year to get
like a half an inch to an inch or they
can break it and they slide a piece of
coral in between the coral because coral
is just like bones made of the same type
of there's a certain my neck yeah coral
in a box in there with a bone to fuse my
vertebrae together cut his neck open to
the front yeah yeah because there's a
bunch of muscle in the back it's easier
to get through through the yeah look
like you don't see any scars or anything
yeah but it's not bad it could be bad
I've seen people wear the one thing
battle scars never [ __ ] forget the
unknown russian soldier oh dude I was at
your house dude in like high school
steak and cheese calm oh my god dude
what the [ __ ] that was like the most
[ __ ] up thing
that was the most [ __ ] up thing on the
internet website still exists it was a a
website dedicated to like just gore gore
people dying or dead like foreign videos
and 4chan before a fortune yeah you can
find pictures of Dale Earnhardt like his
like oh my god dude so so gruesome are
you put this back on is this gonna be
live in that sitter you can actually
keep this on so people can watch it come
back no they can come back and watch it
yeah I don't know
[Laughter]